Harvey Weinstein has been convicted in
another sex crimes sex crimes trial this
time it's in Los Angeles jury found him
guilty yesterday of three charges
including rape but cleared him or failed
to reach a verdict on several other
counts now this follows his conviction
in a sex crimes trial here in New York
City that was nearly three years ago as
Carter Evans reports the disgraced
Hollywood producer faces another 18 to
24 years in prison
today Justice was one in the case of
people versus Harvey Weinstein after a
trial that lasted months and nine days
of deliberations movie Mogul Harvey
Weinstein looked Straight Ahead as the
judge in his rape trial read the guilty
verdict four women had accused Weinstein
of rape and sexual misconduct but the
jury delivered three guilty verdicts
involving only a woman known as Jane Doe
number one she testified Weinstein
attacked her in a Beverly Hills Hotel
room in 2013.
the jury acquitted Weinstein of a sexual
battery allegation made by another woman
and could not reach a verdict on several
counts involving two other accusers
including Jennifer siebel Newsom a
filmmaker and wife of California
governor Gavin Newsom during her
testimony Newsome broke down multiple
times as she alleged Weinstein also
assaulted and raped her in a Beverly
Hills Hotel room in 2005. a mistrial was
declared for their cases after jurors
could not agree on a verdict
I bet Weinstein was the hit-making
producer behind award-winning films like
Pulp Fiction and Good Will Hunting then
sexual abuse allegations surfaced five
years ago igniting the metoo movement
more than 80 women from multiple
countries have come forward since then
including in New York
where Weinstein was convicted of sexual
assault and rape in 2020 and sentenced
to more than 20 years the trial in Los
Angeles gained even more significance to
sexual assault survivors worried
Weinstein could walk free after New
York's highest court agreed to allow him
to appeal his conviction attorney Gloria
Allred represented multiple Weinstein
accusers in both trials they have
demonstrated that empowered and
courageous women
are able to make powerful men
accountable for the injustices that they
have inflicted on women
now lawyers for Weinstein continue to
deny any allegations of sexual assault
sentencing for this trial is set to take
place early next year Weinstein has
completed two years of his 23-year
sentence in New York the state's highest
court will hear Weinstein's appeal in
July Gail